ukraine
good afternoon yesterday unfortunately
we saw again the continued russian
atrocities committed in ukraine
we witnessed the bombing of a civilian
shelter in the theater building in mario
paul a city which continues to be
besieged by russian forces this siege is
inhumane and the bombardment continues
of the city of mario paul this is
reprehensible this constitutes a serious
and grey violation of international
humanitarian law and the siege has to be
lifted the bombardment and the attacks
against civilians in mariopol have to
stop and the same goes for the entire
aggression by russian forces on the
ukrainian territory
yesterday also brought two important uh
events on the international stage that
further underlined the isolation of of
kremlin in its aggression against
ukraine and increased and for the
underlying also the illegality of this
aggression so first the international
court of justice
ordered russia
to immediately suspend its military
operations which started exactly three
weeks ago on the ukrainian territory
this order has binding effect on russia
under international law the court stated
that it was not in possession of
evidence substantiating the allegations
of the russian federation that genocide
has been committed on ukrainian
territory you might remember that this
absurd argumentation was used by putin
in order to justify the invasion of
ukraine
russia has no right under the genocide
convention and the u.n charter to resort
to unilateral use of force in the
territory of another state for the
purpose of preventing an alleged
genocide and the court's order can
therefore be interpreted as clearly
rejecting putin's justification for the
invasion under the international law
so when it comes to putin's aggression
against ukraine and its people
he already lost morally now he is losing
also legally and his isolation
internationally is increasing
also yesterday the committee of
ministers of the council of europe
decided to terminate the membership of
russian federation in this organization
in the council of europe
with its unprovoked and unjustified
aggression against ukraine russia
violated the fundamental principles of
the council of europe statue the u.n
charter and the international law as the
high representative borough said also in
his corresponding statement on this
issue as a result of kremlin's behavior
russian citizens now unfortunately will
no longer benefit from the protections
granted by the european convention of
human rights nor be able to take their
cases or the cases of violation of their
human rights in russia and by russia to
the european court of human rights this
is highly concerning and yet another
restriction of russian citizens rights
which was caused by putin's reckless
policies
we urge the russian federation to
rapidly return to compliance with
international law in particular with
international human rights and
international humanitarian law
merci beaucoup
voces
virginia
questions
yes
no no i'm sorry if
apologies i don't know why those two
names get crossed in my mind all the
time
not really
go ahead
uh thank you eric i have a question
actually on energy
and which is that yesterday the energy
commissioner mrs simpson
held an online meeting with opec
secretary general
mohammed samus
so i would like to ask you what are the
issues discussed and my second question
is when is the energy commissioner
planning to travel to the gulf region
thank you
thank you um question for tim who is
connected online
apologies now up again go ahead
hello yeah as you say uh the
commissioner had a conversation
yesterday um with the
the um secretary general uh of opec
uh and the conversation of course is in
the context of the global challenges
that we face on the energy markets
um as you will know um
in
in recent weeks there's been a
coordinated release of oil stocks
with a number of international partners
to try and ease a little bit the
pressure on on prices in the market so
that's the the context of the
conversation i don't have specific
details um on on
on the topics discussed yesterday any
particular outcomes but that's um that's
what i can say um and i will be happy to
to provide you with some additional
information if you want
in terms of the the commissioner's
travel plans i don't have anything um at
the moment that i can confirm in terms
of upcoming visits to the region um but
as you know there's there's also ways of
of taking contact and and speaking uh
without physically going there and and
those contacts continue and the
commission has spoken with a number of
of her counterparts in recent weeks and
months
thank you very much
are there other questions for us on the
energy dimension
i only see one hand raised
so i don't know if it's on this but even
if it isn't we will move forward now
with this
yes
function
function
foreign
is there anything new any new contacts
with the u and the taliban
on the issue of recognition or on the
other issues human rights etc thank you
thanks a lot for your question nawab
well
what i can say is that there was
lately
actually a
meeting in a mission by the eu envoy to
kabul to continue discussing the
situation in afghanistan
and we can confirm that
he went together thomas nicholson and
the head of the es division of
afghanistan and pakistan
are still actually on mission in the
region this week including in kabul
for security reason of course i cannot
go into details regarding the
arrangements but what we can say
nonetheless is to confirm that they will
have consultations with the un uh the
civil society representatives the
political actors humanitarian ngos
international partners present in kabul
and meetings with the de facto afghanist
afghan authorities
of course the mission
offers an opportunity to demonstrate
that the eu stands with the afghan
people
and to signal to the de facto
authorities that even if the
international community's attention
might be predominantly elsewhere
the eu is also keeping a close eye on
taliban's action
so the visit will also be a good moment
to enhance eu's bilateral dialogue with
the de facto authorities and to follow
up and push for the return of girls and
boys to school at all levels
after the reopening of the schools after
the new year on the 22nd of march and it
will be an opportunity to raise the need
for an inclusive governance and to
review the human rights situation
including concerns over the
arbitrary arrests and enforced
disappearance to which we have also
reacted locally
you're a follow-up noaa
yes thank you eric you mentioned that
they are
in the region so will they be visiting
any other countries besides afghanistan
thank you as i said earlier
i cannot go into details about this
whole
mission but i will keep you informed in
case we have something else to say
thank you very much are there other
foreign relations related questions for
nebila
today
or for peter
that is not the case any other issues
for us today
yes tomato
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
strategy
foreign
foreign
so
[Music]
foreign